given a two-by-two matrix a do you
remember how we found its inverse given
a how did we find a inverse we had used
column and row operations yes elementary
operations do you remember how we solved
it we first write the matrix a as I
times a where I is the identity matrix
or the unit matrix and then we perform
row operations on matrix a to reduce it
to the identity matrix performing the
same row operations on I reduces it to a
inverse and we keep this a as is that's
how we get a inverse using row
operations similarly we get a inverse
using column operations like this a is
reduced to I and this I is reduced to a
inverse now if you remember this
technique was very tedious and long is
there a better and a quicker way to
solve for the inverse of a matrix yes
there is let's look at it on a new page
let's find the inverse of a in a
different way there's a very simple
formula to find the inverse of a matrix
it is equal to 1 over determinant of a
multiplied by the adjoint of a this is
the formula of a inverse 1 over
determinant of a multiplied by the
adjoint of a so all we really need of
the inverse is the determinant and the
adjoint of the matrix no row or column
operations needed but there is one
important condition here and it's
intuitive the determinant of a cannot be
equal to 0 in fancy words we can say
that matrix a has to be a non singular
that's because the denominator cannot be
equal to 0 so before finding the adjoint
let's first find the determinant of a
what will be the determinant it will be
2 times 3 minus 5 times 1 6 ma
five is one the determinant of a is
nonzero matrix a is non-singular so this
formula will work now we need to find
the adjoint of a do you remember the
shortcut to find the adjoint of a 2x2
matrix we interchange these two and
change the sign of these two so what
will be the adjoint here 2/3 will be
written as 3 to 5 will change to minus 5
and 1 will change to minus 1 interchange
and change the sign now that we have
both we move on to finding a inverse the
determinant of a is 1 so 1 over
determinant of a will be 1 over 1 we
write the adjoint of a as is solving
this will give us the inverse of a now 1
over 1 is 1 multiplying the scalar 1
with every element will keep the
elements unchanged so a inverse will
equal this matrix to verify the answer
try multiplying matrix a with this one
and you should get the identity matrix I
feel this was clearly easier as compared
to the row or column operations in the
next part of the video we will find the
inverse of a 3 by 3 matrix using this
formula
you